hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another video this is the first video
that I'm doing for into it and they've
got a new contest going where they're
going to be giving away five thousand
dollars every day for 15 days in
december all you have to do is go to
love our local business calm and
entering a reason why you deserve to win
the five thousand dollars is what you're
going to spend it on and you have your
chance to win so in today's video I'm
going to share some my top secrets and
tools that I like to use and if I had
five thousand dollars and I was
budget-conscious entrepreneur how i
would spend it so i hope you enjoyed the
video and i'd love to hear we have to
think after you watch it number one
improve your online marketing one of the
most cost-effective ways to market your
business is online it's never been
cheaper or easier to acquire customers
and with the right tools and strategies
you can get a significant return on any
investment you make here are a few ideas
to help you get started boost your
search engine optimization or SEO as
your traffic converts well because they
are usually people who are looking for
an answer to a problem they have a pain
and you can help them solve it they'll
sign up with you take a look at hub saw
its marketing greater which is free for
a quick list of suggestions on what you
can do if you want to go more in-depth
check out a CO masz they tell you
specifically what's wrong on your
website give you weekly rankings reports
for your important keywords and you can
teach you step-by-step about SEO if
you're interested in learning more
there's a free trial for 30 days then
pricing starts at ninety nine dollars a
month get or use a newsletter a
newsletter is one of the most powerful
tools that you can have in your online
marketing arsenal not many people will
come to your website and buy immediately
they'll want to learn more about you and
your business browse around and then
make a decision if you don't capture
their information when they visit your
website you're relying on them to
remember to come back to your site and
most people won't use a newsletter to
turn a browser into a prospect and a
prospect into a customer give them a
reason to sign up for example a free
bonus a white paper downloads and
discounts and then give them value ID
content on a regular and consistent
basis my tool of choice here is a weber
i have over 65,000 subscribers and every
week I send the value I email to them
that helps position me as an expert at
what I do my favorite feature is that
they tell
the likelihood of your emails going to
someone's spam folder and they give you
suggestions for what to do to score
better they have a one dollar trial and
affordable pricing depending on the size
of your list get some design help having
a professional image online can go a
long way to making people trust you and
want to work with you make your website
look respectable and your marketing
materials don't scream out amateur a
great resource for entrepreneurs is
99designs if you need any kind of design
help think logos website business cards
banners mobile app brochures etc I'd
start here you put in your project in
your budget and people from around the
world will start submitting designs with
most graphic designers you have to look
at their previous work and hope that
they'll do a good job on your project
with 99 designs you get to see the final
product itself and only pay if you
choose a winning design design started a
couple hundred dollars and are typically
very cost effective number to bring on
some help as entrepreneurs we wear too
many hats and our list of to do's never
seems to end to grow your business at
some point you need to build beyond
yourself it also doesn't have to cost
you a lot of money to get going the
first person I hired was for one hour a
day just to free up my time to focus on
higher priority projects here are two of
my favorite resources to help you bring
on some help without draining your bank
account odesk Otis is the world's
largest and fastest growing place
outsource your work to online hundreds
of thousands of talented people from
around the world bid on your project
which can range from a one-off deal to a
full-time position I've hired people and
Odessa do admin work video editing right
ain't ran scription graphic design
telemarketing and be a personal
assistant the rates are extremely
competitive and you can see how well
they've done from other employers and
their ratings on previous jobs if you're
looking for for part-time work or
full-time help and you don't physically
need someone in your office ie almost
every job would actually be your first
stop fiber fiber is a website where
people list what they will do for you
for five dollars they are usually very
simple task which for them is easy but
few might cause a lot of frustrations
need a video transcribed need to install
a new wordpress blog need help with an
Excel function need to translate some
text there's someone on fiber who will
do it for you for five bucks make sure
to look out for people who have positive
ratings and our
perience sellers if you need something
specific done that you can't find anyone
for you can also post a request and
people will bid on that project as well
be careful though the fun & bizarre
category can get addictive and kill your
productive time as you explore the
depths of things people will do for five
dollars number three improve your
productivity there are never enough
hours in a day to get everything we need
done fortunately the number of great
tools that can help us do the things we
need to do more efficiently here are
some of my favorites accounting software
this might seem a little self-serving on
this is on into its blog but I don't do
work for into it I'm an entrepreneur if
you don't have a County software like
QuickBooks for your business yet it will
dramatically improve your productivity
every quarter I download my visa
statements into my accounting software
and in 20 minutes undone my bookkeeping
invoicing managing your cash flow
budgeting is also much easier to do with
software like QuickBooks as
entrepreneurs we need to spend time
focus on where we add the most value to
our business unless you love sitting
down every month with your shoebox of
receipts an Excel spreadsheet pick up a
copy of quickbooks and make better use
of your time to grow your company other
tools there are so many tools that i use
to boost our productivity that i can't
go into details on each one right now
but if you have any specific questions
just let me know most of them are either
free or very reasonably priced here's a
quick list of some of what I use for
binding domain names I use godaddy
hosting my website i use bounce web for
sinking sharing and backing up my files
i use dropbox for coordinate with my
team and running surveys i'll use google
drive for automating my scheduling i use
time trade for going paperless i use
scansnap and evernote to save time by
creating a home page dashboard I use a
notepad never forget any of your
passwords again by using lastpass
quickly learn about your contacts by
using rapportive and Zab knee get
desktop reminders for Google Calendar
using G minder productively stay on top
of the news using google reader
instapaper enzyte stay on top of news
for your clients use google news alerts
manage your social media accounts using
HootSuite create google sitemaps and
find internal broken links i use g site
crawler
to schedule and space up my tweets i use
buffer and for analytics on my twitter
account i use crowd booster that's a
partial list of my favorite tools but it
should hopefully give you a few ideas to
dig deeper into again if you have any
questions about these tools or other
tools just leave a comment below and
I'll answer it for you number four give
your marketing a boost we've already
talked about the importance of online
marketing see point number one don't
forget about traditional marketing to it
doesn't have to cost a lot of money and
for creative entrepreneurs and queen
easy way to get more attention for your
company and drive more business here are
two quick low-cost ways that I market my
business and how you can do the same get
in the media when you read a newspaper
are you paying attention to the ads of
the story advertising can work but it's
expensive and takes time getting the
story written about you however can have
an immediate impact and the only cost is
your time when I first started out I
built my own media list of reporters I
wanted to reach out to and every week
emailed them a new story idea every week
at least one of them said yes and it
helped me get a lot of media attention
early on now i use PR leads as my tool
of choice every day they send you
stories that reporters are actually
working on and are looking for expert
help with if your background matches up
with a reporter story you contact them
and have the chance to be featured in
the article PR leads has got me into the
new york times forbes and countless
other publications the cost for the
service is ninety nine dollars a month
recognize your clients who doesn't level
when companies recognize them even
sending something as simple as a card
that someone can help improve their
loyalty and cause them to buy more and
refer new clients to your business it's
basic marketing but unfortunately not
something that people do enough of
especially in this digital age my
favorite tool to help me here is send
out cards they have a wide variety of
cards to choose from and all you have to
do is type in a message include the
address and they'll print it seal it
stamp it and mail it for you how simple
is that you can also attach gifts to the
card if you want to go the extra mile
try sending out the brownies we always
get a great reaction when we send them
to our clients it really works try it
number five invest in yourself if you
stop learning your company will stop
growing your business will always be
limited by how much you know so the more
you know the better here are two ideas
to help you invest back into yourself
without spending a lot of money
mastermind groups I run to mastermind
groups in Toronto for entrepreneurs and
whether you are joining an existing
group or creating your own it's an
extremely valuable tool the format we
use which you're free to dock is to meet
once per month at a set time in place
everyone then has 20 minutes to talk
about the challenges that they've been
facing and get input from the group the
goal is in the talk for 20 minutes but
to introduce a problem and let the group
help you out it works best when you have
memories in a group who are different
industries and have different skills
from what you're good at you not only
get ideas that help you solve your
challenge there's also something about
being around the other entrepreneurs
that can help you stay motivated and
realize that you're not alone again this
post is just an intro into a lot of
topics so if you have any questions
about mass my groups feel free to leave
in the comments below when I'll answer
it for you training whatever you're
interested in learning there is training
out there for you you might be online it
might be in person it might be from a
book set a goal to learn something new
every quarter and go out and execute the
more you make improvements the more your
business will grow I've created my own
line of worksheets for entrepreneurs
that might help if you're just getting
started I'd also recommend checking out
last minute training they are Canada's
largest training marketplace and sell
access to training classes at discounted
rates across the country
thank you for joining me for another
video if you guys like the video you
want to see more please give it a thumbs
up below I'd also love to hear what you
have to think if you won't leave a
comment I always check this out it makes
want to do more of these videos for you
guys when I see them and don't forget if
you want your chance to win the five
thousand dollars every day for 15 days
in december just go to love our local
business calm and enter for your chance
to win i'll see you soon
you
you